welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain
please join me in welcoming dr. mark
Richardson dr. Richardson has pioneered
the nurse surgical use of interventional
MRI robotics gene therapy and closed
loop brain stimulation he is also the
founder of the brain modulation lab
which conducts human systems
neuroscience research using intracranial
recording and stimulation he directs the
epilepsy and movement disorders surgery
program at the University of Pittsburgh
Medical Center for complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen dr.
Richardson's talk title is basal ganglia
cortical loop function during speech my
name is dr. Sheena Kashia and I will be
a moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinths we
would like to extend our special thanks
to the brain initiative program
directors in particular dr. James Mack
for their efforts in organizing today's
session before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting your questions
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions in the drop down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
by email following the presentation this
presentation is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the far right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Richardson
thank you for that introduction this
presentation is going to cover a
relatively new area an invasive human
neuroscience research and that's the
role of the basal ganglia in producing
speech so this project is funded through
the brain initiative it's part of a
mechanism called research opportunities
using invasive neural recording and
stimulating technologies in the human
brain and the reason that's important is
that
this is entirely new mechanism over the
past several years that it's really
specific to opportunities that present
themselves during neurosurgical cases
where neurosurgeon neuroscientists and
our teams are able to learn about the
brain through things that we need to do
with patients clinically while we're
recording and then simulating from the
brain so this project specifically looks
at the role of the subthalamic nucleus
and the cortex and interactions between
the two during speech production it's a
combination of investigators from the
University of Pittsburgh Carnegie Mellon
University and also Johns Hopkins
alright so most models of language and
speech production focus almost entirely
on neural activity at the cortical level
and here's an example of different
models and one primary reason for this
is a lack of direct access to deeper
parts of the brain so through
neuroimaging and through EEG it's easier
to get a readout on what the cortex is
doing while someone talks but it's very
difficult through functional
neuroimaging methods to get a read on
what's happening at the subcortical
level and there's a lot of important
network activity that happens there and
the reason we know that is that all of
our actions are not mediated solely by
neural activity of the cortical level
but rely on communication through basal
ganglia thalamocortical loops so here's
a schematic of that and this is showing
loop for motor control where you have
signals that go from the cortex into the
striatum back through the thalamus to
cortex and this occurs in segregated
loops here's one for more executive
function and here's another for
potentially more limbic or associative
functions and these networks are
separated for the most part obviously
there's some integration so that we can
coordinate emotions with motor behavior
for instance but these pathways are also
used in speech just that there haven't
been really good ways to study this in
the past so we know the basal ganglia
participate in speech because the basal
ganglia participate in all motor and
cognitive actions but specifically
speech is disrupted in Parkinson's
disease and in other disorders of the
basal ganglia and specifically in
Parkinson's disease this can result in a
number of problems that make it very
difficult for patients to communicate
they lose lost ability to impart emotion
to their speech that's called prosody
they have some purely motor articulatory
problems they have a significant issue
with hypo phone yes and that's volume
control and then one side effect from
DBS really we really don't know why it
happens but it's probably the most
common side effect from subthalamic
nucleus DBS is that your decrease in
verbal fluency so with all these issues
for Parkinson's patients medications
don't work very well and DBS can work
for some motor aspects of speech but
sometimes it can make other aspects
worse so there's a real need to
understand this better and our team in
fact works where patients are undergoing
deep brain stimulation for movement
disorders like Parkinson's disease and a
central tremor briefly DBS is a platform
for delivering small amounts of
electrical current to specific parts of
network that's affected in movement
disorders that electrical impulse is
controlled by battery or pulse generator
it's essentially a small computer which
usually resides in the chest and this is
what it looks like up close so this is
its real size in relation to a dime
there are different models now they have
more than these four contacts but we can
both stimulate through these and we can
also record off these electrodes and
then as part of the surgery to implant
these electrodes patients are
traditionally
and therefore we have the opportunity to
ask them to do things like speak while
we can record from various structures in
the brain they're involved in speech
network so deep brain stimulation
surgery is really the only opportunity
to record neural activity in the human
brain directly from basal ganglia
structures there's not any other
clinical indication currently for
putting electrodes in these areas and
awake patients this is what looks like
for a DBS patient in the operating room
here I'm working with my physician
assistant and a resident surgeon here's
the patient who's comfortably position
with a stereotactic frame and we're
doing some motor testing in this case
but we have learned to take advantage of
this opportunity to look at speech and
this is an overview of how we're doing
that so specifically we're interested in
the role of the subthalamic nucleus and
how it interacts with the cortex and
there are a couple reasons for that one
is opportunistic and that we quite often
implant the stn for DBS and Parkinson's
disease but the other is that that's the
one structure in the basal ganglia
pathway at least downstream that's
directly connected to cortex through the
so called hyper direct pathway that was
pictured in the schematic previously and
so through introducing stimuli which can
be words that are read or spoken to the
patient that can hear them in headphones
we can look at what's happening in the
brain when this stimulus is produced a
cue to speak and look what happens
during the production or output of
speech and we can also in the third
panel on the right we can use electrical
current to disrupt different aspects of
speech production based on predictions
that we generate from a model we can
develop from data that we obtain from
recording in these brain regions so
again here's a schematic of you can see
the hiker direct pathway coming to the
SCN and initially our work is focused on
motor loop for speech here's another
schematic of what
the experimental setup looks like so we
typically would insert three electrodes
into the subthalamic nucleus as part of
the brain mapping portion of the case in
order to determine that we're in the
right spot and it's routine to do this
with patients awake so that we can test
them and we can get a signature of the
subthalamic nucleus that we can use to
make a determination at the electrodes
in the right spot
so these clinic electrodes record single
units from the tip of the micro
electrode and then there's a ring
contact record local field potentials
which is three millimeters above the tip
we can also through the burrow hole
which you can see depicted as kind of
the ring around the leads at the top of
the cortex we can insert a soft flexible
strip electrode and in our case we use a
60/30 contact micro eco array that's
very easy to slide over the cortex and
we have a method of aiming this stereo
tactically in the operating room for the
sake of time I'll just show you some
images you can see what this looks like
and here's a patient again positioned in
the operating room the stereotactic
frame in this case there's a microphone
boom microphone that's positioned in
front of patients mouth and we have the
same setup each time and then the
research team is watching the
presentation you can see top that's on
the monitor on the right upper panel and
you can see the purple consoles that are
the the word that the patient's hearing
then we also see their response and
we're recording that data at the same
time we're recording if you look in the
lower panel on the right those are
single neuron spikes and so we're
recording single unit activity that's
our clinical recording system and we're
recording local field potentials at the
same time
all right here's an image of what one of
these electrodes look looks like really
soft in flexible plastic you can see
that so actually our NIH uo1 consortium
is just writing up a safety paper if
anyone's wondering is this safe to do
this has been done now in hundreds of
DBS patients without any complications
related to placement of the electrode so
we feel like it's really safe and it's
also we think this is somewhat of an
aside a precursor to a time when we may
be implanting centers like this along
with closed-loop GPS devices so that
devices are reading from the cortex and
using that information to decide how to
stimulate at the subcortical level um if
you look at the panel on the right this
is a representation of what we can see
in real time in the operating room so we
can verify that using gamma activity
related to speech onset that we're
looking in the right spot and then this
is ad hoc or representation of game
activity on the cortex on the right side
of that right the animal the next slide
is going to show the behavioral task at
least the what I'm going to talk about
today so a few slides back I showed the
schematic of the electrode over the
cortex and I didn't mention it then but
indicated on that slide is the fact that
we can record over m1 s1 and also this
superior temporal gyrus so auditory
cortex first task that we set up and for
which I'm going to show you data today
it was a reading task but currently
we're engaged in an auditory repetition
task so we can look at how the s T
information from the STG participates in
basal ganglia loop activity but this is
what the Baker will test looked like for
the data I'm going to show you so there
were a series of words and non words
that were presented on the screen to
patient Brendan okay well what what have
we found this far
first interesting thing is that some
flame nucleus neuron activity is dynamic
during speech production so there's not
just one thing that's happening that's
not unexpected from the literature about
stn function in general much of that
literature's from non-human primates in
movement and then some are some of that
literature's from cognitive tasks work
in humans and there's really debate
about what the SDN the basal ganglia do
in general but one thing we can say is
that firing rates both increase and
decrease relative to the onset of speech
this is a plot of many different neurons
and whether there was an increase or
decrease and when that happened in the
firing rate then this is an example on
the left side the upper side of a neuron
that increased its firing rate and one
that decreased its firing rate is on the
bottom and you can see that that
decrease actually happened before the
onset of speech which is time zero you
can look at this paper in Journal of
Neuroscience if you're interested and
seeing this more detail for the time
being I'll show you this figure from the
paper which makes a point that firing
rate increases were more likely to be
locked to the actual onset of speech
while decreases in firing rates were
more likely to be locked to the cue so
some cognitive planning aspect of speech
production at least that's a hypothesis
so you can see the firing rates on the
left side of these panels are aligned in
relation to cue and then you see in the
second panel the relationship to the
firing rate increase or decrease and the
production latency and then the panel on
the right shows the correlation
coefficients of the production latency
for those that for each neuron relative
to production interval and then the cut
it's color-coded based on whether the
neuron firing rate increased or
decreased and what we found was
essentially that
Hieu locked decreases in firing rates
were common and production locked
increases in firing rates so we're
working our way through what we think
that means but there appears to be some
dynamic coding of speech and yes TN so
next what we did was move to looking at
what's happening in the cortex at the
same time we've done that so far with
local field potential recordings from
each area so this is the first study
that where anyone this has ever recorded
from the sub-link nucleus in the cortex
at the same time this is also recently
published in material neuroscience and
these are images just showing an
overview of where we recorded the next
slide will show some of the data so we
were interested in this question of
whether or not there is any specificity
for articulatory features and neural
activity in the SDN so we know from the
work of others that there's topography
for this and the sensory motor cortex
that's SMC and the data on the right we
know that this could be tracked with
gamma activity we know there's a beta D
synchrony before the onset of movement
or speech but we found something similar
in the subthalamic nucleus as well and
if we look actually starting on the
right just to to orient to the cortex
which most people are more familiar with
you can see in the panel that's showing
the volume basically over which we
recorded that there's a topography for
where lips and read or recording
locations are separated from and below
and then you can see the time frequency
plot on the right lots on the right and
then you can also see two examples one
where lip where tongue was
differentiated from lips that stop when
and then where lips was differentiated
from Tug on an individual contact at the
time of speech onset in terms of the hi
cam
activities so some selectivity for the
articulatory feature versus time and we
found something similar in terms of
being able to differentiate this at the
individual contact level and the
subthalamic nucleus based on high gamma
activity but the difference is that
there there didn't seem to be a
typography for that and we are also
working our way through what we think
that means that really the these areas
that were selectively really do appear
to be scattered about it would it be
helpful if we had even more recordings
and we do have more recordings that so
we're looking to replicate this finding
in some of our newer data
okay so some additional finding so just
mentioned for the sake of time so we've
also found that some flaming nucleus
activity and activity in the cortex
tracks with gain adjustments during
articulatory movements and this is
measured in the speech and speech
pathology field by the format ratio so
we see some correlations between XI
lower frequency oscillatory activity not
high gain back to the lower frequencies
that track with forman ratio on a per
patient basis the data that I showed
also suggest a role for the subthalamic
nucleus in speech planning because we
see SCN activity that occurs prior to
the onset of speech this isn't entirely
surprising because we know that the
basal ganglia participates in motor
planning it's really not clear how
however and what specifically is being
done and what cortical areas are
influencing various parts of the SDN on
a functional level that we can
appreciate in the operating room and the
reason this is important is because as
we think about how to develop new DBS
therapies we need a better understanding
of how how and where information is
traveling through this network and then
some really tantalizing new work is not
ratio in this presentation but we also
run this task in patients where we can
report from the thalamus and in fact are
seeing a laterality effect in terms of
discriminating words and non words based
on neural activity in the thalamus so
that wraps it up I just mentioned this
but the overall goal this work is to
build a better neurological framework
that will allow us to improve a deep
brain stimulation or disorders like
Parkinson's disease and other basal
ganglia disorders where speech
communication becomes a real
patience thank you thank you dr.
Richardson for that innovative
presentation as a reminder our speaker
will follow up with any questions about
his presentation by an email coming up
next please join me in welcoming dr.
Juan Garcia we'll be discussing his
groundbreaking work inducing cortical
plasticity by brain stimulation and
rehabilitation hoped to see there